i think we should play the uh tape here
where he projects we played this the
other day but this is this is he's he's
phoning it in he continues the phone he
literally is phoning in it right he's
literally phoning in his confession here
i'm not kidding he's confessing to a lot
of [ __ ] here in this i mean it's 42
seconds and he
he admits to like three federal crimes
here on this 43 seconds it's insanity
but let's listen to the um alpha get
cucked here and let's listen a lot of
people think that when you walk into my
office i have confidential documents or
whatever it may be all declassified but
i had confidential documents spread out
all over my far floor
and uh like a slob
like i'm sitting there reading these
documents all day long or somebody else
would be it's so it's so dishonest when
you look at it and so people were were
concerned because they said gee
you know that's a strange scene you look
at the floor and you see documents right
they have cover sheets of documents no
they put them there john and they put
him there in a messy fashion and then
they took a picture
and they released it to the public and
this is what we're dealing with with
these people do you remember the uh
documentary interview where he's like i
look orange i look like he's like
why do i look can we fix that why do i
like horn this is the same [ __ ]
i mean here's here's my question is
they're so upset they're like oh he made
it look sloppy and they put it on the
ground this and that like i don't know
what the actual layout of his office is
because we only see the photos where he
takes the people and he gives the
[ __ ] dumbass thumbs up right right
but
kim jong-un yeah in front of the i'm
shaking kim jong-un's hand and all this
stuff but when you
stop and really think about this would
he have been like okay or like happier
if they had like neatly stacked them
right in like three rows a four column
like is that what he had been okay with
would republicans not be outraged if
they just laid them out next to each
other in an organized fashion like
that's what i'm trying to say that's
what i'm trying to understand here i
if if you're trying to find logic in
that 42 seconds of nonsense that we just
listened to everyone's got a grandpa out
there right i mean everyone is kind of
grandpa and you know grandpa reaches an
age where half the time when he's saying
[ __ ] it doesn't make any sense it just
doesn't make any sense he's saying all
kinds of [ __ ] you smile and you nod and
you go yeah grandpa yeah that's a great
story
the only thing is the difference between
my grandpa and this grandpa is my
grandpa didn't violate the [ __ ]
espionage act